This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是有电梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《百分之二》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代社会中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些磨难，你将会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的姿态迎来新生。收听《百分之二》。也就是数字2%。可在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听。回顾过去播客。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。1984年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在IHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执业专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界传递的信号是，你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你非得这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA Radio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试结果两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这花费了一大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean is.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《二十几岁的心理学》，在这个播客里，我们探讨二十几岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们意味着什么。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode, back for another topic.
对于我们的心理学。大家好。欢迎回到这个节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听另一期节目，探讨另一个话题。
Before we get started today, I just wanted to let you guys know that I have a Patreon and I would really appreciate if you considered supporting the show. It is just me on this end of the microphone, writing our episodes, researching them, recording them, editing them, and it's a lot of work. So I really appreciate all the added support, additional support,
在我们今天开始之前，我只是想让大家知道我有一个Patreon账号，如果你能考虑支持这个节目，我将不胜感激。在这只麦克风的这一端只有我一个人，撰写我们的节目、做研究、录音、剪辑，这有很多工作要做。所以我真的很感激所有额外的支持，额外的支持，
that you lovely listeners and my amazing psychology community choose to contribute. So have a look over there for bonus content, transcripts, early access to episodes, and so much more. And as always, if you have an episode suggestion or just any ideas on what we're discussing any of your own thoughts or inputs, you can DM me at that psychology podcast. But back to the episode, we are going pretty deep today. We are bearing all with possibly one of the hardest questions. I think we have to ask ourselves in a relationship when we know it isn't working. When is it time to walk away? When do we know that it's over? I know this is a question that
你这群可爱的听众和我的心理学社区选择做出的贡献。所以去那边看看独家内容、文字记录、抢先收听节目以及更多内容。和往常一样，如果你有什么节目建议，或者对我们讨论的任何内容有任何想法，或者你自己的想法和意见，你可以私信我@thatpsychology podcast。但回到节目本身，我们今天要深入探讨。我们将坦诚面对可能是我们在关系中必须问自己的最艰难的问题之一，当我们知道它行不通时。什么时候才是该离开的时候？我们什么时候才知道一切都结束了？我知道这是一个问题
can haunt a lot of us, maybe has haunted us in the past, especially when we don't want to let go, but we know that we should. We know that there are really valid reasons behind this gut instinct that we're having. So what I really want to do is use this episode to provide some of the psychology and the research that indicates when and why certain relationships don't work, what keeps us holding on, and the reasons we ignore those warning signs or the reasons we ignore reasons to leave, not just bad, but also some of the more neutral reasons, like just not feeling fulfilled or happy. I think ultimately our 20s are not meant to be spent worrying if someone is right for us or it should not be spent,
可能会困扰我们很多人，也许过去曾困扰过我们，特别是当我们不想放手，但我们知道我们应该放手的时候。我们知道，在我们内心的这种直觉背后，其实有着非常正当的理由。所以我真正想做的是利用这一集提供一些心理学和研究，这些研究指出了何时以及为什么某些关系会破裂，是什么让我们紧抓不放，以及我们忽视这些警告信号的原因，或者我们忽视离开的原因，不仅仅是糟糕的原因，还有一些更中立的原因，比如仅仅是感觉没有得到满足或不快乐。我认为归根结底，我们的二十几岁不应该用来担心某人是否适合我们，或者它不应该被用来，
I guess, in a relationship that is shrouded in doubt. So if that is you right now, firstly, my heart goes out to you. But I also hope that this episode, gives you the guidance that you're looking for at this kind of fork in the road. Like I said before, I think the reason I really wanted to tackle this topic today is because I think one of the hardest dilemmas we have to face is whether to walk away from someone you still love because you know the relationship isn't right for you, because you know you deserve more or you are just at your core not happy. And that decision or even that line of questioning, that doubt, it can come up for a lot of reasons.
我想，是在一段充满疑虑的感情中。所以，如果现在的你正是如此，首先，我的心与你同在。但我也希望这一集能为你在这类人生的十字路口时提供你一直在寻找的指引。就像我之前说的，我想我之所以真的想在今天探讨这个话题，是因为我认为我们必须面对的最大难题之一，就是是否要离开一个你依然爱的人，因为你知道这段感情不适合你，因为你知道你值得拥有更多，或者你打心底里不快乐。这个决定，甚至这行质问，这种疑虑，可能会因为很多原因而产生。
Maybe the passion isn't there anymore, there's a lack of effort, you're growing apart, you have different futures, you're fighting all the time, and then again also things that are more insidious like cheating or emotional and physical abuse. But I also think, and I saw someone say something very similar to this the other day, and I couldn't agree more. your relationship doesn't have to be toxic, your partner does not have to be terrible or be a bad person for you to want to leave. It doesn't have to be a relationship that is marked by fights or even abuse or irreconcilable differences. It can just be unfulfilling. You can just be wanting more.
也许激情不再，缺乏努力，你们渐行渐远，你们有着不同的未来，你们一直在争吵，然后还有一些更隐蔽的事情，比如出轨，或者情感和身体上的虐待。但我也认为，我前几天看到有人说了非常相似的话，我不能赞同更多。你的感情不一定非得是有毒的，你的伴侣也不一定非得是个糟糕的人，你才可以想要离开。它不一定非是一段伴随着争吵、甚至虐待或不可调和的分歧的感情。它可能只是无法让人满足。你可能只是想要更多。
And I think just being unhappy or exhausted is a valid reason. If this is, isn't what you want. If you know that you're drained or unsatisfied, you don't have to stay with someone just because you have a history or because they treat you really well or you have your family or friends' approval for this person in your life. That's something that I think keeps us very stuck. We think there needs to be some problem or some fault for us to end things. But really at the end of the day, it's your life, this is your time, these are your days to prioritize your well-being. and you don't want to look back in 10 years time, in a year's time, and realize that you wasted time being with perhaps the wrong person
而且我认为仅仅是不快乐或筋疲力尽就是一个充分的理由。如果这不是你想要的。如果你知道自己已经被榨干或感到不满，你不需要仅仅因为你们有一段历史，或者因为他们对你真的很好，或者你的家人或朋友认可这个人进入你的生活，就和某人在一起。我认为正是这一点让我们陷入僵局。我们认为需要有什么问题或过错，我们才能结束一段关系。但说到底，这是你的生活，这是你的时间，这些是你的日子，你应该把你的福祉放在首位，你可不想在十年后、一年后回首往事时，才发现自己把时间浪费在了可能错误的人身上
just because you were maybe scared to upset others or maybe just scared of being lonely. Please, please, from me to you, do not waste the best years of your life on someone who isn't right for you. that is something that you will regret. As someone who has been there, done that, got the T-shirt, and who still does see all the good in my previous relationships and all the amazing growth that they have given me,
仅仅因为你可能害怕惹恼别人，或者可能害怕孤独。求求你，求求你，从我到你，不要把最好的年华浪费在一个不适合你的人身上。那会是你最后悔的事。作为一个曾经经历过、做过、甚至拿到过T恤衫的人，并且依然能看到我以前的所有恋情中的所有美好以及它们带给我的所有惊人成长，
I still wish time and time again that I had left earlier. Basically, what I'm trying to communicate is that there can be a myriad of reasons, but in that moment, what you're going through is going to feel so deeply personal and conflicting. I think often we can also feel stuck in kind of what we would call a processing loop or a thought spiral to end things or not and contemplating what that might mean for us. How will we move forward? What next? Where do you go from here?
我仍然一次又一次地希望自己能早点离开。基本上，我想传达的是，原因可能有很多，但在那一刻，你正在经历的事情会感觉如此深刻、私密且充满矛盾。我认为很多时候我们也会陷入所谓的处理循环或思维漩涡中，纠结要不要结束关系，并琢磨这对我们意味着什么。我们将如何继续前进？接下来呢？从这里你将走向何方？
It's this concept of the what ifs that I think really haunt us. What if things just get better? What if I make a mistake by making this decision? What if I hurt this person? And a big one is what if I leave them and they treat the next person, exactly how I wanted to be treated. That's a really big one for a lot of us, knowing that this individual who you might still love will inevitably at some stage no longer be part of your life and will probably find someone new, live a life without you, and I think that's something that we
正是这种“如果”的概念真正困扰着我们。如果情况好转了呢？如果我做这个决定犯了错呢？如果我伤害了这个人呢？其中很大一个问题是，如果我离开他们，而他们对下一个人却完全如我所愿地那样对待呢？对于我们许多人来说，这是一个非常重大问题，明知这个你可能依然爱的人在某个阶段将不可避免地不再是你生命中的一部分，并且可能会找到新的人，过上没有你的生活，而我认为这是我们
can't cope with, that uncertainty, that unknowing. We never enter into a relationship thinking that it's going to end. These what-if thoughts, they can become quite intrusive. and result in a lot of overall anxiety, things like trouble falling asleep, having a hard time concentrating because you are weighing up every answer. Or maybe you also just wait patiently for things to change. You know, deep down in your gut, at the core of your intuition, you know what you need to do. That is a reminder that I want you to take from this today. But there is always some impulse, some fear that holds us back.
无法承受的，那种不确定性，那种未知。我们进入一段关系时，绝不会想到它会结束。这些“如果”的想法，它们会变得非常具有侵入性。并导致大量的整体焦虑，比如难以入睡，很难集中注意力，因为你在权衡每一个答案。或者也许你只是耐心等待事情发生改变。你知道，在你的内心深处，在你的直觉核心，你知道你需要做什么。这就是我希望你今天从中得到的提醒。但总有一些冲动、一些恐惧阻碍着我们。
And here's the thing. I think sometimes we think that intuition is not a particularly scientific, valid, reliable concept or idea, but there is a growing body of evidence that suggests that humans are born with this very basic, emotionally intuitive ability, this ability to immediately respond to something that is highly emotionally potent or arousing, and we respond with a decision or an interpretation that is correct. we know what is right and wrong even without thinking about it, you know, thoroughly, even without contemplating every single option. You know, for example, watching your partner across a room, talking to your friends and realizing that they're not the one. That gut instinct can be correct because the stomach and the heart, they contain a significant amount of neural tissue. and that neural tissue is connected to the brain.
事情是这样的。我想有时我们认为直觉并不是一个特别科学、有效、可靠的概念或想法，但越来越多的证据表明，人类生来就具有这种非常基本的、情绪直觉能力，这种能够对高度具有情感潜能或唤起性的事物做出直接反应的能力，并且我们用正确且带有解释的决定做出回应。我们甚至不用去彻底思考，甚至不用去权衡每一个选项，就知道什么是对是错。你知道，例如，看着你的伴侣在房间的另一头，和你的朋友聊天，然后意识到他们不是对的那个人。这种直觉可能是正确的，因为胃和心脏，它们含有大量的神经组织。并且这些神经组织与大脑相连。
It's called the gut brain and heart brain axis. And we know that neurotransmitters and hormones like dopamine and serotonin, they will influence cognitive processes and they will influence our decision-making and our emotions. And those biochemical signals also contribute to our intuitive responses. Basically, sometimes you are correct to trust your gut when it comes to things like this. I also want to make the final point that your 20s are not the time to be in a relationship that is not fulfilling you or that is just incredibly hard work or putting your well-being or your other relationships, your friendships under strain.
这被称为肠脑和心脑轴。我们知道多巴胺和血清素等神经递质和荷尔蒙会影响认知过程，它们会影响我们的决策和情绪。这些生化信号也有助于我们的直觉反应。基本上，当涉及到这类事情时，有时你相信自己的直觉是正确的。我还想最后强调一点，你的二十几岁绝对不是身处一段无法满足你、或者极其辛苦、亦或是给你的福祉或其他人际关系以及友情带来压力的感情中的时候。
That time for self-sacrificing and that level of commitment, it will come. It will come one day. But right now, I think if you have doubts, that is a huge warning sign. and it's a sign that you already know what your answer is to that question. When is it time to walk away? So let's also break down some of the other key reasons or indicators after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
那种自我牺牲的时代和那种程度的承诺，它会到来的。总有一天会到来的。但现在，我想如果你有疑虑，那就是一个巨大的警告信号。这说明你其实已经知道自己对于那个问题的答案是什么了。什么时候才是该离开的时候？那么在短暂的广告休息之后，让我们也来剖析一些其他关键原因或指标。百分之二。这就是有电梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier,
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《百分之二》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代社会中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你将会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的姿态迎来新生，
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
收听《百分之二》。也就是数字2%。可在I-Hart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金规则。规则一，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你在玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。
And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
规则二，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《女朋友》这个新季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？
The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts,
警察似乎并不关心。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女朋友》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio app、Apple Podcasts上，
wherever you get your podcast. You remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
无论你在哪里收听播客。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小姬姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我的意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊一聊快克，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始发现这里有一条贯穿始终的线索。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts.
目前我们也在讨论艾滋病的问题。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比今年更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听回放。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it
欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难的选择》（Learn the Hardway），我是主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师Keer Gaines。在心理健康意识月之际，我将结合十多年来在心理健康领域的自身经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的嘉宾包括Tripp Fontaine、Ryan Clark。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会过于深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，而我们却依然在追逐。
and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在看记分板。生活变成了一场关于输赢的竞赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），是因为你们觉得在世时做一个好人很重要吗？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the hard way.
绝对是。而且这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我的新播客《艰难的选择》，由我Kear Gaines带你一起，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. So I want to outline how we know when it's time to walk away. If you have your doubts or a gut instinct that this relationship is not right for you, hopefully some of these reasons can confirm or maybe deny your intuition. Firstly, if you just don't love them anymore and that connection is gone, the things that you used to adore about them no longer make you excited or power. or interested, I think that is a huge indicator.
打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索Learn the hard way并立即收听。所以我想概述一下我们如何知道是时候该放手了。如果你心存疑虑，或者有一种直觉认为这段感情不适合你，希望其中一些原因能够证实或否定你的直觉。首先，如果你不再爱对方，这种联系已经消失了，那些你曾经倾心于他们的特质不再让你感到兴奋、充满活力或感兴趣，我认为这是一个巨大的信号。
Love is sometimes a bit of a fickle emotion, and obviously it's impossible to be in the active state of love all the time. A reaction and emotion like this, I don't think it can be sustained at that level of intensity for so long, but it's about more so those quiet moments when you sit and think about your partner, when you pause and you focus on all the things you like and you're, about them, your shared memories, do you still love them? In that moment, do you still love them? Do they make you feel happy and special and warm? Or have they kind of just become a secondary character in your life, an acquaintance? There's two things I want to say about this point,
爱情有时是一种善变的情感，很显然，不可能每时每刻都处于热恋的状态。像这样的一种反应和情感，我认为不可能长期维持那种强度的水平。但它更多的是关于那些安静的时刻：当你坐下来思考你的伴侣，当你停下来，专注于所有你喜欢他们的方面、你们共同的回忆时，你还爱他们吗？在那一刻，你还爱他们吗？他们是否让你感到快乐、特别和温暖？还是他们已经在你的生活中变成了一个次要角色、一个点头之交？关于这一点，我有两点想说，
though. Firstly, I think love is something I do think that we can work on. But the question to ask yourself is, is that really the kind of work that you're willing to do right now? And I think that's a question I can't answer for you. That is entirely personal. Are you willing to make efforts to fall back in love with your partner? I also think that you can still deeply love someone and know that the relationship isn't right for the both of you. Love is kind of seen as this very irrational emotion for many reasons and I think this is one of them. You can love someone and still know that the conditions of your relationship are not what you want them to be. You can still be annoyed by their actions or feel the attraction fading or just know that it's not going to make you
不过。首先，我认为爱是我们确实可以努力去经营的东西。但你需要问自己的问题是：这真的是你现在愿意付出的努力吗？我认为这是一个我无法为你回答的问题。这完全是个人选择。你愿意为了重新爱上你的伴侣而付出努力吗？我也认为，你仍然可以深爱一个人，但同时又清楚这段感情并不适合你们双方。由于种种原因，爱在很多情况下被视为一种非常不理性的情感，我认为这就是其中之一。你可以爱一个人，但依然清楚你们关系的现状并不是你想要的。你可能仍然对他们的行为感到恼火，或者感觉到吸引力在消退，或者只是知道这不会让你
happier for much longer. You know that you deserve better. Sometimes also the things that we initially really loved and adored about someone can come to be the reason that we fall out of love. It's this idea known as fatal attraction theory. And what it argues is that what attracts us to your partner in the first place is often the reason that the relationship ends. So they've done a few studies on this in one of them. A researcher recruited, I think, around 300 university students. And she asked them to list the qualities that attracted them to their former partner. And then they were asked to list the qualities in their partner that led to the breakup.
更长久地快乐。你知道你值得拥有更好的。有时候，我们最初真正喜欢和倾心于某人的特质，最终也可能成为我们不再爱他们的原因。这就是所谓的“致命吸引力理论”。该理论认为，最初吸引我们走向伴侣的原因，往往也是最终导致关系破裂的原因。因此，他们对此进行了一些研究，在其中一项研究中，一名研究人员招募了大约300名大学生。她让他们列出吸引他们前伴侣的特质。然后，他们被要求列出伴侣身上导致分手特质。
And she found that 30% in 30% of those cases, those traits were the exact same ones. And some of the common ones were being with someone who was initially really fun and spontaneous, but in the long run, as you think about the future, what it sometimes mean is that they really can't take anything seriously or they're very unpredictable. Or maybe you are seeking a partner who seems really strong and assertive, but that can become quite uncompromising or authoritarian. Our perception of these character traits, the ones that we desire in a partner, they will change over time, especially as we mature and we also change as people. and that is why we can sometimes fall out of love with the person that we once adored.
她发现，在30%的案例中，这些特点是完全相同的。其中一些常见的特点是：和一开始非常有趣、随性的人在一起，但从长远来看，当你考虑未来时，有时这意味着他们真的无法认真对待任何事情，或者他们非常不可预测。或者，你可能正在寻找一个看起来非常坚强和自信的伴侣，但这可能会变得相当不妥协或专制。我们对这些性格特征的认知，即我们在伴侣身上渴望的特质，会随着时间的推移而改变，尤其是随着我们日渐成熟以及我们作为人的改变，这就是为什么我们有时会不再爱那个我们曾经倾心的人。
And that's really okay. That's really natural, especially when we are young, especially when, like most of us, we are in our 20s. And it kind of goes without saying that a lot of us don't really know what we're looking for yet. I think a big tell that this has potentially occurred in your relationship is if you no longer want to spend time with your person. Common interests and a desire to to spend time together, they are some of the main predictors of the success of a relationship in the long term. And often one of the most important factors that is going to indicate just a basic underlying attraction or longevity of the relationship. So if that drive towards each other has faded, maybe you find yourself preferring to spend time with your friends or
这其实完全可以理解。这是非常自然的，尤其是当我们年轻的时候，尤其是当像我们大多数人一样处于20多岁的时候。不言而喻的是，我们中的很多人其实并不知道自己在寻找什么。我认为，这可能已经发生在你的关系中的一个重要信号是：你不再想和你的伴侣共度时光。共同的兴趣和想要共度时光的愿望，是长期关系成功的主要预测指标之一。通常也是表明基本潜在吸引力或关系持久性的最重要因素之一。因此，如果那种朝对方奔赴的动力已经消退，也许你发现自己更愿意和朋友共度时光，或者
constantly postponing date nights or spending time together because you don't really want to see them, I think that's a very clear indicator that perhaps your time together has come to an end. Secondly, another big reason is if you no longer care what you're fighting about or what you're fighting for. My mum always said to me, you know the relationship is on the rocks when you no longer feel the need to invest in solving an argument, when you are just resigned to the conflict, because I think this indicates that you don't care about the future of the relationship, unconsciously, deep down, you kind of know it's not worth the energy of a fight. I think that the occasional disagreement or argument is actually pretty healthy because it shows that you both care,
经常推迟约会之夜或一起度过的时间，因为你其实并不想见到他们，我认为这是一个非常明显的信号，表明你们在一起的时间可能已经走到了尽头。其次，另一个重要的原因是，如果你不再在意你们在为什么争吵，或者你们在为什么而战。我妈妈总是对我说，你知道这段感情触礁了，是因为你不再觉得有必要投入精力去解决争论，当你只是对冲突听天由命时，因为我认为这表明你并不在乎这段感情的未来，在潜意识里，在内心深处，你其实知道它不值得你花力气去争吵。我认为偶尔的意见不合或争吵其实是相当健康的，因为它表明你们双方都在乎，
you have kept your own individual opinions, you have your own emotional lives. And I obviously do not mean fights that are hurtful or turn emotionally or even physically abusive, but in every relationship, even friendships, you're not going to be 100% a lot. aligned on everything. And so sometimes it's good to get that out there and to agree to meet each other in that space of temporary conflict or disagreement. There's actually this concept. I'm not sure if I'm a fan of it, but I'm going to talk about it anyways. It was termed by this man called Terry Real. It's known as normal matrimonial hatred. And I know that sounds really intense, but basically the premise is that every relationship is a reflection of the spectrum.
你们保留了各自独立的观点，拥有各自的情感生活。我显然不是指那些具有伤害性、演变成情感甚至身体虐但在任何关系中，甚至在友谊中，你不可能在所有事情上都百分之百意见一致。因此，有时把这些表达出来，并同意在那种暂时的冲突或分歧的空间中互相妥协是件好事。其实有一个概念。我不太确定自己是否喜欢它，但我还是要讲一下。这个概念由一个叫特里·雷尔（Terry Real）的人提出。它被称为“正常的婚姻仇恨”。我知道这听起来很强烈，但其基本前提是：每一段关系都反映了我们作为个体所感受到的情感光谱。
of emotions that we are going to feel as individuals. And sometimes that spectrum is going to involve things like anger or frustration or even hatred. And so being able to express those freely but in a healthy way, one in which you're both invested in coming to a solution or helping the other person is really, really valuable. And maybe this is controversial, but like I said, it's healthy to sometimes feel anger or frustration towards your partner. Obviously not to an irreparable degree. And I think when you can't even be bothered to argue or be bothered to fix those things, you just feel apathy. I think that is a sign that it's time to walk away from your relationship. Thirdly, if being with them is going to or is
而有时这个光谱会包含愤怒、沮丧甚至仇恨等情绪。因此，能够自由地表达这些情绪，但要以健康的方式——即你们双方都投入到寻找解决方案或帮助对方中——是非常非常有价值的。也许这会有争议，但就像我说的，对伴侣有时感到愤怒或沮丧是健康的。当然，不能达到无法修复的程度。我认为，当你甚至懒得去争吵或懒得去修复这些问题，而只剩下冷漠时，我认为这就是是时候离开这段关系的信号。第三，如果和他们在一起将要或者正在
currently taking you away from your own life or your own dreams rather than elevating them, I personally think it's time to leave. I think this is particularly important for those of us in our 20s because it is during this decade that we must be in the business of cultivating our own independent lives. Your dreams, your goals, your ambitions cannot wait for anyone, especially not for someone you're not 100% sure of because you risk throwing out some of the best years of your life, regretting some of the decisions you didn't make for a person who may one day, just be a stranger. If they're making you feel terrible about yourself or they're keeping you
将你从你自己的生活或梦想中拉开，而不是提升它们，我个人认为这是离开的时候了。我认为这对于我们20多岁的人来说尤其重要，因为正是在这个十年里，我们必须致力于开创我们自己独立的生活。你的梦想、你的目标、你的雄心壮志不能等待任何人，尤其是不要为一个你没有百分之百把握的人等待，因为你冒着抛弃人生中最美好几年的风险，为某个有一天可能只是个陌生人的人，去后悔你没有做出的决定。如果他们让你对自己感觉糟糕，或者阻止你
from doing something you've always dreamed of, I don't think that's it. For example, you know, if you have an amazing job offer to move overseas or to a new city, it's your dream job, but the person you're with doesn't want to move or doesn't want to do long distance and they're asking you to stay, I think it's your duty to take that job. No matter what they try and say, it is your duty to claim your independence and your own dreams and really just do what's best for you to kind of protect and be selfish with your golden years and i know that that is going to be a very hard decision i know that saying that and doing it is a completely different thing but this is your foundation these are your experiences the ones that you will hopefully recount for the rest of your life
去做你一直梦想的事情，我认为那就不对了。例如，你知道的，如果你有一个绝佳的工作机会去海外或去一个新的城市，这是你梦想中的工作，但和你在一起的人不想搬家，或者不想维持远距离恋爱，他们要求你留下，我认为你的责任就是接受那份工作。无论他们试图说什么，你的责任是宣示你的独立和你的梦想，真正做对你最有利的事情，去保护并自私地对待你的黄金年代。我知道这将是一个非常艰难的决定，我知道说出来和做到完全是两码事，但这是你的基石，这些是你的体验，是你希望在余生中反复讲述的经历，
the ones that will transform your identity. And I really do believe that you need the right person by your side in those moments who is willing to encourage you and be your biggest cheerleader. I also think the best sign of a healthy partner is someone who wants good things for you more than you do, who is going to inspire you to take risks and follow your dreams, knowing that it might not be what's best for them, but it's going to be what's best for you because they are equally as invested in your future. Also, you know, if this person is your soulmate,
是那些将重塑你身份的经历。我真的相信，在那些时刻，你需要一个正确的人陪伴在你身边，他愿意鼓励你，做你最大的啦啦队队长。我还认为，健康伴侣的最好标志是：他比你自己更渴望你过得好，他会激励你去冒险，去追随你的梦想，即使他知道这可能不是对他最好的选择，但对你来说是最好的，因为他们同样对你的未来投入了心力。还有，你知道的，如果这个人是你的灵魂伴侣，
not only will they A want what's best for you, but who knows, maybe you will end up together in the future. Maybe you'll come back together. I've seen this happen with friends of mine who have broken up with their partners because of big life changes, different goals, and they've come back together. Later on, a few years down the track,
不仅他们A会希望你过得最好，而且谁知道呢，也许你们未来还会走到一起。也许你们会重新复合。我看到我的朋友们身上发生过这种事，他们因为生活发生重大变化、目标不同而与伴侣分手，后来在几年后，
when they realized that they wanted this person in their future and they were willing to make it work. But I don't think it should require such an intense, excessive degree of self-sacrifice. I think this regard for the future, your future, their future, it really links to the next reason. Your values and your plans for the future don't align. I think sometimes when we are dating in our 20s, we feel like we are going to be going to be young and carefree forever. And that we have all the time in the world. The time is infinite.
当他们意识到他们希望这个人出现在自己的未来并且愿意为此努力时，他们又复合了。但我不认为这应该需要如此强烈、过度的自我牺牲。我认为这种对未来的关注——你的未来、他们的未来——确实与下一个原因息息相关。你的价值观和对未来的规划不一致。我认为有时候我们在20多岁时约会，我们会觉得自己将永远年轻、无忧无虑，并且我们拥有全世界的所有时间。时间是无限的。
And maybe it's because I'm now in a relationship with someone wonderful where thinking about the future does not make me want to throw up. And I feel that we are very aligned on some core things. But that has really made me have this renewed belief in the fact that compatibility is more than just physical chemistry. You also need to have very core shared values and be openly able to communicate about what that means for the future, not just for your future as an individual, but as a couple, especially if things are kind of getting to that point of getting pretty serious. If that vision is completely different, if they want kids and you want to go and solo travel and those experiences are both core to your own beliefs and inner value, I don't think any amount of wishful thinking is going to change either of your minds.
也许是因为我现在和一个非常棒的人谈恋爱，想到未来并不会让我感到反胃。我觉得我们在一些核心问题上非常一致。但这确实让我重新坚信了一个信念：契合度不仅仅是身体上的化学反应。你们还需要拥有非常核心的共同价值观，并且能够公开沟通这对未来意味着什么，不仅是你作为一个独立的个人的未来，也是作为一对情侣的未来，尤其是当事情发展到相当严肃的阶段时。如果这种愿景完全不同，如果他们想要孩子，而你想去独自旅行，而这些经历对你们各自的信念和内心价值观都至关重要，我不认为任何一厢情愿的想法能够改变你们任何一方的想法。
It's something I'm learning the older I get. You cannot change someone through love. You just have to accept them for who they are and hope they accept you as well and hope that it's a fit. Loving them more, needing them more will not alter what might be an ugly truth. That deep down you know that you are just different. And if one of you has to give up, perhaps what's a lot of you. is a huge life goal, that can at times foster a lot of resentment that may eventually erode your
这是我随着年龄增长正在学习的一点。你无法通过爱去改变一个人。你只能接受他们本来的样子，并希望他们也接受你，并希望你们是合适的。更爱他们、更需要他们，并不会改变那个残酷的真相：从心底里你知道你们就是不同。如果你们中必须有一个人放弃也许是很大一部分的自我，一个宏伟的人生目标，有时这会滋生很多怨恨，最终侵蚀你们
relationship in the future. It's going to be a hard conversation, but I think you both deserve to be with someone who wants the same things, or maybe just be alone to fulfill some of those lifelong dreams that you honestly owe it to yourself to complete. Fifth, if you are trying too hard. Now, I think there are two schools of thoughts when it comes to relation. relationships and this dimension of them. One is that they should be easy, that they should feel easy and safe. They shouldn't be hard work. They shouldn't be a struggle.
未来的感情。这将是一场艰难的对话，但我认为你们都值得和一个追求相同目标的人在一起，或者也许只是独自一人去实现那些你确实亏欠自己去完成的终身梦想。第五，如果你过于勉强。现在，我认为关于感情和感情的这个维度，有两种思想流派。一种是感情应该是轻松的，应该让人感到轻松和安全。它们不应该是辛苦的工作。它们不应该是挣扎。
And the second school of thought is that relationships require work, like anything else in life. You need to be invested and kind of willing to put in the miles. Regardless of what you think, I personally think neither is wrong, neither is right. you should not be the only one putting in effort or trying too hard to cling on to the relationship. If they don't make you feel special, if they are not putting in the time, if they are taking you for granted, that is not it. That is not it. It's this very core relationship principle in psychology known as reciprocity. Each partner has to give back what the other one is putting in.
第二种思想流派是，和生活中的任何事情一样，感情需要经营。你需要投入并愿意付出里程。无论你怎么想，我个人认为两者无所谓对错，你不应该是唯一一个付出努力或勉强维系这段感情的人。如果他们没有让你感到特别，如果他们没有投入时间，如果他们把你的付出视为理所当然，那就不对了。那绝对不对。这是心理学中一个非常核心的关系原则，被称为“互惠原则”。每个伴侣都必须回报对方所投入的.
And when that becomes unbalanced, I think we begin to feel really unappreciated. We feel the foundation kind of crumbling. Like we are constantly exhausted from that mental, domestic, emotional load. The mental load is a really interesting concept here and it probably deserves its own episode. But essentially, it's this idea that one partner and it's normally the woman takes on a lot of the emotional and mental effort. of being responsible for thinking about planning, organizing all parts of the relationship and your life together. You are the one organizing dates. You're the one organizing weekend plans, what you're going to eat for dinner, where you're going to travel to. And whilst some people really enjoy this,
而当这种平衡被打破时，我想我们开始感到真正的不被欣赏。我们感到基石在崩塌。就像我们 constamment 因为精神、家务、情感负担而精疲力竭。这里所说的“心理负担”是一个非常有趣的概念，它可能值得单独出一期节目。但本质上，它是这样一种观点：一个伴侣（通常是女性）承担了大量的感情和心理努力，负责思考、规划、组织关系的各个部分以及你们的共同生活。你是那个组织约会的人。你是那个组织周末计划、晚餐吃什么、去哪里旅游的人。虽然有些人真的很享受这一点，
for others, and I would say for most of us, we want a partnership from our partner. We want to be able to rely on them when we're tired, when we have a lot to do, when we have a lot, going on. And if you have communicated that to them and you've communicated what you need, what you want, and they have been on compromising, unwilling to offer you that, not investing as much as you are, I think that requires a really hard look at the future of that relationship. One thing you should keep in mind is this idea in psychology known as equity theory. And it was first proposed in the 80s and it's often used to understand relationship breakdown, and even at times things like infidelity or cheating.
但对其他人来说——我想对我们大多数人来说——我们希望伴侣能与我们并肩作战。当我们累了、有很多事情要做、有很多事情在进行时，我们希望能够依靠他们。如果你已经向他们传达了这一点，你已经传达了你的需求、你想要什么，而他们却妥协、不愿意为你提供这些，没有像你一样投入，我认为这就需要认真审视这段感情的未来。你应该牢记的一点是心理学中被称为“公平理论”的概念。它最早在80年代提出，常用于理解关系的破裂，甚至有时用于理解不忠或出轨等事情。
Our relationships last when we believe that the relationship is equitable and fair and that the distribution of labour and investment is also equal. The longer that that becomes unbalanced, the more the resentment builds. The more we are likely, as this research says, to do things that perhaps undermine our relationship or look, for a way out. Also, if you are at this point, if you relate to this, ask yourself, do you want to spend your 20s being someone's parent, being their caregiver, cleaning up after them, feeling like you are not appreciated? If you're going to be in a relationship, let it be an adult one
当相信关系是公平合理的，且劳动力和投资的分配也是均等的时候，我们的关系才能持久。这种失衡持续的时间越长，积怨就越深。正如这项研究指出的那样，我们越有可能做出可能会破坏我们关系的事情，或者寻找
where you feel cared for, that your needs are equally as important, that they're happy to occasionally take care of you and to do the dishes or just the bare minimum. And my final reason, I think this reason is an absolute non-negotiable, it is time to walk away if you are being disrespected or you don't feel like this person treats you well enough. We all deserve a very standard, bare minimum level of treatment and sometimes that is not going to be what someone can offer you. And it's not always because they don't love you, right? There may be other things going on, maybe your love languages don't align, maybe they're struggling with attachment issues, maybe you just haven't communicated enough. Those are things that I think we can work through at
出路。另外，如果你正处于这个阶段，如果你能产生共鸣，问问自己：你想把20多岁的时光花在做别人的父母、做他们的照顾者、为他们收拾残局、感觉自己不被欣赏上吗？如果你要谈恋爱，那就谈一场成熟的恋爱：在那样的关系中，你觉得被关爱，你的需求同样重要，他们乐意偶尔照顾你、洗碗，或者只是做到最低标准。我最后的理由，我认为这个理由是绝对不容妥协的：如果你正在遭受不尊重，或者你觉得这个人对你不够好，是时候离开了。我们都理应得到一个非常标准的、最低限度的对待，有时这并不是某人能够给予你的。这并不总是因为他们不爱你，对吧？可能还有其他事情在发生，也许你们的爱的语言不一致，也许他们正在与依恋问题作斗争，也许你们只是沟通得不够。我认为这些是我们可以克服的事情，
times, like I said, if you're willing to do the work. But then there are other behaviors that are absolute non-negotiables, if they are being coercive, if they're asking you not to see your friends, controlling your behavior, belittling you amongst so many other things, that is not the kind of relationship that you deserve or that you should be in at any age or stage of your life. These kinds of behaviours, this belittling, this making you feel bad about yourself, perhaps even coercive control, needing you to constantly be there for them if they need you, that does not come from a place of love. Never.
正如我所说，如果你愿意付出努力的话。但除此之外，还有一些绝对不能妥协的行为，比如他们对你进行精神虐待、要求你不要跟朋友见面、控制你的行为、贬低你等等。无论你在人生的哪个年龄或阶段，这都不是你应得的、也不是你该身处的那种关系。这种行为，这种贬低，这种让你对自己产生负面情绪的做法，甚至可能是强制控制，要求你在他们需要时时刻随叫随到，这些都不是出于爱。绝对不是。
That comes from a place of selfishness and control and authority. and I really don't think that that is a place you need to be in. I know that it's still very difficult to make that decision to leave because although we know that it's problematic, we are probably very much aware of how this is making us feel, those kinds of relationships that are highly almost abusive or bonded or coercive or controlling, they create very deep trauma bonds. And they can also feel and at times can be very,
那是出于自私、控制欲和权威。我真的觉得你不必身处那样的关系中。我知道要做分手的决定依然非常困难，因为尽管我们知道这段关系有问题，我们也可能非常清楚这种感觉有多糟糕。那些高度近乎虐待、依附、强制或控制的关系，会产生非常深层的创伤依附。离开它们不仅感觉上非常、
very dangerous to leave. If you find you're not comfortable telling your family or your friends how this person treats you or that you feel the need to protect them or hide certain parts of your relationships, those are very clear early warning signs. Someone who loves you will treat you with respect, period. End of discussion. It is time to leave. And I also want to put some resources in the episode description. If this does apply to your situation, I wish I could talk about it more, but I also think that that deserves its whole own singular episode
而且有时也确实非常、非常危险。如果你发现自己难以向家人或朋友倾诉这个人是如何对待你的，或者你觉得有必要保护他们、隐瞒你们关系的某些方面，这些都是非常明显的早期预警信号。真正爱你的人一定会尊重你，句号。讨论到此结束。是时候离开了。我也想在节目简介中附上一些资源。如果这种情况确实发生在你身上，我希望能谈论更多，但我也认为这个话题本身值得做一整期单独的节目，
for those of us who might be going through that. I think my perspective on ending a relationship, despite all of the what-ifs, despite maybe still being in love with them, is that there will be a period of time where it's going to hurt, and it's going to be hard. But that period of time can start now,
专门留给那些可能正在经历这种状况的人。我对结束一段关系的看法是，尽管有各种“万一”，尽管可能依然爱着对方，但总会有一段时间会感到痛苦、会觉得艰难。然而这段痛苦的时期现在就可以开始，
or it can start in three months. or it can start in a year and you'll wish you'd done it earlier. You'll wish that you'd have given yourself more of that time to heal and move on. You wish that you claimed that time as your own. But there's no doubt that it's not an easy decision. So why is that? What are some of the psychological and emotional barriers to making this kind of choice? One that we intuitively know might be necessary and yet we cannot seem to follow through. Well, that's what I want to talk about next as well of some of the ways to ease the pain and some encouragement for those of you still looking for the motivation. So all of that and more after this short break.
也可以在三个月后开始，或者在一年后开始，到时候你会后悔没有早点这么做。你会希望自己能留出更多时间来疗伤和前行。你会希望把那段时光夺回来，真正属于自己。但毫无疑问，这不是一个容易的决定。那么为什么会这样呢？做出这种选择有哪些心理和情感障碍？有些是我们凭直觉就知道是必要的，却怎么也无法付诸行动的障碍。好吧，接下来我想谈谈这些，以及一些缓解痛苦的方法，并为那些仍在寻找动力的人提供一些鼓励。所有这些以及更多精彩内容，就在这段简短的广告之后。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthy, your person.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield.
收听《2%》。节目英文名为 T-W-O-Persent，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。玩蠢游戏，就会得到愚蠢的下场。法则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield）。
And in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no.
在《女友们》（The Girlfriends）全新一季中，天哪，这竟然是同一个人。一群女性发现她们竟然都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. You remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我发誓。我要成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击了莉儿·金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉儿·金到底有什么关系？你可以通过《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客寻找答案。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那些时光的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, for it's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）合作的节目，大谈 80 年代的快克（毒品）。说实话，这对我来说意义重大，不仅因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊快克，只是为了让你们知道。我是说，马克，这是我们第二期讨论快克了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿的线索了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。
Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
然后你接上了这句话。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。收听《回顾过去》，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。
Welcome to my new podcast, learn the hard way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kier Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难中学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kier Gaines）。为了迎接心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，并与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we're, We've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时我们在追求某样东西时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算，我们已经做得够多了。因为人们总是在记分牌上盯着看。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正发自内心地做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app, Search learning a hard way and listen now. Ending a relationship is painful. Let's not sugarcoat that fact.
加入我的新播客《艰难中学习》，由我基尔·盖恩斯带你进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App，搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。结束一段关系是痛苦的。我们无需粉饰这个事实。
And I think we often think that the person who's being broken up with is the only one who deserves to feel that grief and feel that pain. But making that decision, knowing what you might be giving up that this person will not be your person anymore, is a decision that brings its own unique set of emotions, including grief, including heartbreak. And maybe that stigma around being the person who does the breaking up is what keeps us in the wrong relationships for way too long.
而且我认为我们经常以为，被分手的那个人才是唯一一个理应去感受那种悲伤和痛苦的人。但是做出那个决定，明知你可能会放弃什么——这个人将不再属于你——这个决定本身就会带来一系列独特的情感，包括悲伤、包括心碎。也许正是关于“作为提出分手的那个人”这种社会污名，才让我们在错误的感情里停留了太久。
I remember when I was with someone previously debating for months and months about what to do. And I think it was something that we both knew needed to happen, but neither of us could do it. Neither of us wanted to be kind of the one to pull the trigger. our romantic relationships become somewhat of an anger for us, both in good ways and bad ways. They can keep us really steady, but an anchor can also keep you stuck in one place and left feeling detached from yourself, kind of aimlessly floating or deeply unhappy. And you do not deserve to be unhappy.
我记得以前跟某个人在一起时，我曾纠结了几个月该怎么做。我想那是我们俩心里都清楚迟早要发生的事，但谁也迈不出那一步。我们俩都不想做那个按下扳机的人。我们的恋爱关系在某种程度上成了我们的精神锚点，无论是好是坏。它们能让我们保持稳定，但锚也会让你困在原地，让你感到与自己疏离，有些漫无目的地漂泊，或者感到深深的不幸福。而你绝不应该感到不幸福。
Not now, not ever. You truly do deserve the absolute best. And I know right now that can be really hard to see. It's hard to see that there are better. things out there or a future beyond this person, but I want to assure you that there is, the world is beautiful and wide and so surprising, and it's filled with incredible richness. Right now, you're kind of probably experiencing tunnel vision in your relationship, but I promise time is an amazing thing. It heals all of those wounds. So what are some of the things that are
现在不要，永远不要。你真的值得拥有绝对最好的。我知道此刻这可能很难看清。很难看到外面还有更好的事物，或者在这个人之后还有未来，但我向你保证，未来是存在的。这个世界美丽、辽阔而又充满惊奇，它蕴含着无与伦比的丰富内涵。此刻，你可能正对这段感情产生视线狭隘的“隧道视野”，但我向你保证，时间是一件神奇的事。它能抚平所有的伤痛。那么，是什么在阻止
preventing us from making this very hard call? The first one I always think of, is, is this concept of sunk costs. If you're not familiar with this idea, essentially our brains sometimes think of things like relationships as an investment. Now this is more of an economics concept than a psychological one,
我们做出这个艰难的决定呢？我首先想到的，就是“沉没成本”的概念。如果你对这个想法不熟悉，本质上来说，我们的大脑有时会把像恋爱关系这样的事情看作是一种投资。这其实是一个经济学概念，而不是心理学概念，
but we have seen research that shows that the same reason that people make dodgy investments or purchases is the same reason people stay in bad or unfulfilling relationships. The sunk cost fallacy is this cognitive bias that makes you feel like you need to continue being with this person, putting love, time and
但我们已经看到研究表明，人们做出糟糕的投资或购买决定的原因，与人们留在糟糕或无法满足自己的关系中的原因是相同的。沉没成本谬误是一种认知偏差，它让你觉得你需要继续和这个人在一起，将爱、时间和
energy into this relationship rather than walking away because you've already lost so much by being with them for so long. We continue to invest because by leaving, we feel like we are losing out on all that time we've already given them, thinking that if we stay, maybe that won't be a waste and that it will be worth it. This fallacy or this bias, it causes us to make irrational decisions that are not aligned with our best interests. And you know if you have been with this person for a while, if you live together, maybe you're engaged, your family loves them, you've built this life with them. And that is going to make it more difficult to end a relationship compared to a two-month
精力投入到这段关系中，而不是选择离开，因为你和他们在一起这么久，已经失去了太多。我们继续投资是因为通过离开，我们觉得自己失去了之前付出给他们的所有时间，认为如果我们留下来，也许这一切就不会白费，而且会是值得的。这种谬误或偏差会导致我们做出不符合我们最大利益的非理性决定。而且你知道的，如果你和这个人在一起有一段时间了，如果你同居了，或者订婚了，你的家人也很喜欢他们，你和他们一起建立了这种生活。相比于一段只持续了两个月的
fling where that is a much more short-term investment. It's the same thing as being comfortable. Once you sometimes feel safe with someone, you can become complacent. Once you feel very intensely comfortable, you put up with a lot more difficulties or insecurities or unhappiness because you worry it will cost you even greater unhappiness to leave this person than what you are tolerating right now. That reasoning makes you stay, even if it's not an accurate calculation. I want to say also I'm not saying that your relationship shouldn't be comfortable.
露水情缘，这是一种短得多的投资，结束一段长期的关系会要困难得多。这和贪恋舒适感是同一回事。一旦你有时在某人身边感到安全，你就会变得自满。一旦你感到极其舒适，你就会忍受更多的问题、不安全感或不快乐，因为你担心离开这个人所付出的不快乐代价，会比你现在所容忍的还要大。这种推理让你留下来，即使这不是一个准确的计算。我也想说明，我并不是说你的感情不应该让人感到舒适。
it should be absolutely the most safe feeling. It should feel like home. But if you are staying because that's what you're used to and because you are scared of the unknown, that may not be the best choice when you consider all the other factors. The next reason is expectant thinking. And oh my goodness, if I don't see this all the time,
它绝对应该带给你最安全的感觉。它应该感觉像家一样。但如果你留下只是因为那是你习惯的，并且因为你害怕未知，那么当你权衡所有其他因素时，这可能并不是最好的选择。下一个原因是“期待性思维”。天哪，我不是无时无刻不在看到这种现象，
even in my own past relationships. It is so unbelievably common. It's similar to the what if thought pattern. It's this sense of belief that's, something one day is going to change, particularly that your partner might change. We enter into the state of kind of optimistic delusion, whereby we believe that things will be different, that we can change them, things will turn around, and we just need to do X or Y, or get married, or move in together, or spend more time apart, or improve this one little thing about their
甚至在我过去的感情中也是如此。这实在是太常见了。它类似于“万一……”的心态模式。这是一种信念，即总有一天情况会改变，特别是你的伙伴可能会改变。我们进入了一种乐观的幻想状态，相信情况会变得不同，我们可以改变他们，事情会好转，我们只需要做 X 或 Y，或者结婚，或者同居，或者花更多的时间分开，或者改善他们个性的这一个小方面，
personality, and it will all be perfect. And I think being optimistic is, a very beautiful personality trait, but I also don't believe that people are able to change who they are at their very core. That is something that is ingrained in them from birth, from early experiences, from formative events, and it takes a lot of effort to shift that, a shift that I don't think we can force someone into. Reflect on what you can do, what you would want to do if this thing doesn't change. What is the future here? Will you actually be, happy if they continue to be this version of themselves, if they do not put in effort, if they continue to do this thing that deeply annoys you or leaves you feeling let down. I also think that if
一切就会变得完美。我认为保持乐观是一种非常美好的个性特质，但我也坚信，人们无法改变他们最核心的本性。那是从出生、从早期经历、从成形事件中根深蒂固的东西，改变这一点需要付出巨大的努力，这种改变是我们无法强迫别人做到的。反思一下，你能做什么，如果事情没有改变，你想怎么做。这里的未来在哪里？如果他们继续保持这个版本的自己，如果他们不付出努力，如果他们继续做那件深深惹恼你或让你感到失望的事，你真的会快乐吗？我也认为，如果
you're listening to this episode, perhaps you already know the answer to that. And you know that perhaps what you have been engaging in is not realistic, but expectant thinking. Also, sometimes we think that we won't be able to do better than what we have. Maybe this person you're with is completely fine. They're nice enough. They're good to you. Everyone loves them. They're friendly.
你正在收听这一期节目，也许你心里已经有了答案。你知道自己可能一直在沉溺于不切实际的“期待性思维”，而不是面对现实。此外，有时我们认为自己无法找到比现有条件更好的人。也许你身边的这个人完全没问题。他们人挺好。对你也很好。每个人都喜欢他们。他们很友善。
But you just want more. That is still a perfectly acceptable reason. And believing that you deserve more is the only confirmation you need to know that you deserve more. Maybe you want more passion. You want a deeper connection. More things in common. Greater compatibility. There are millions of people in the world you can be with.
但你只是想要更多。这依然是一个完全可以接受的理由。相信自己值得拥有更多，就是你需要获得的唯一确认，它证明了你确实配得上更好的。也许你想要更多的激情。你想要更深的情感连接。更多的共同点。更高的契合度。世界上有数百万人可以与你相伴。
You do not need to settle with someone just because they are good enough. That's really, I don't think, what we're aiming for in life. Good enough is not the level. Sometimes, though, what can hold us back are a number of very instinctual human fears. And they are the fear of the unknown, the fear of change or uncertainty, and the fear of loneliness, all very core to our inherent drives and basic needs. breakups are a very big relational and social shift and a lot may have changed since you were last single you may have lost a few friends you may have moved graduated lost some of your interests
你不需要因为一个人“还过得去”就委曲求全。我觉得这真的不是我们在生活中应该追求的目标。“还过得去”并不是我们应有的标准。然而，有时阻碍我们的，是一系列非常本能的人类恐惧。它们分别是：对未知的恐惧、对改变或不确定性的恐惧、以及对孤独的恐惧。这些都深深植根于我们内在的驱动力和基本需求之中。分手是一个非常重大的关系和社会转变，自从你上次单身以来，很多事情可能已经改变了。你可能失去了一些朋友，可能搬了家、毕了业、失去了一些兴趣爱好，
transformed as a person so you don't really know what you're entering back into you don't really know what it feels like to be alone and that is scary but i think it is in those moments of being uncomfortable and uncertain that we experience the greatest growth. Your future self is going to thank you for making this hard decision. When all the dust has settled, you will be very grateful. Trust me, you really will. Things may be scary for a while. You probably will feel lonely and you will miss them. That is only a natural part of the kind of disintegration of a personal bond. But with time, that becomes easier and then one day you wake up and you realize it was all for the best that it needed to happen loneliness is just an emotion it's just a feeling it comes and goes it dips and rises and you will be
作为一个人，你已经蜕变了，所以你并不真正知道自己将重新进入怎样的生活，你也不太清楚一个人孤独是什么感觉，这让人感到害怕。但我认为，正是在这些感到不适和不确定的时刻，我们才能经历最大的成长。未来的你会感谢自己做出了这个艰难的决定。当尘埃落定之时，你会非常感激。相信我，真的会这样。事情可能会可怕一阵子。你可能确实会感到孤独，而且你会想念他们。这只是个人羁绊瓦解过程中很自然的一部分。但随着时间推移，这会变得更容易，然后有一天你醒来，你会意识到这一切都是为了你好，这是必须要发生的。孤独只是一种情绪，只是一种感觉。它来来去去，有起有落，
okay through it all you will be stronger you will be better you will find someone better i just really truly deeply believe that you should not be with someone who is not adding to your life in your 20s. This is your time to be your own person to prioritize exactly what is going to make you happy, not stay out of obligation or because of fear or expectation. Is this the life that you want with this person? Are they making you the best version of yourself? Are they making you happy? Why don't you deserve someone that is or who does do all those things? Even if it takes a while, even if they're not right around the corner, even if in the meantime you feel a little bit lost or you feel a little bit alone. It's all about that trial and error. I also want to say you're not a failure just because
在这一切经历中你会安然无恙，你会变得更坚强，你会变得更好，你会找到更好的人。我真的、真心、深深地相信，在你的二十多岁，你不应该和那些无法为你的生活带来积极影响的人在一起。这是你做回自我、优先考虑那些真正能让你快乐的事情的时期，而不是出于责任感、恐惧或期望而勉强留在一段关系中。这真的是你想要和这个人共度的人生吗？他们有没有让你成为最好的自己？他们有没有让你快乐？为什么你不值得拥有一个能够做到这一切、或者本来就能做到这一切的人呢？即使需要花一点时间，即使那个对的人还没出现在转角，即使在此期间你觉得有点迷茫或者有点孤独。这一切都是关于试错的过程。我还想说，你并不是一个失败者，仅仅因为
this didn't work out. This is part of the human experience. People change. You change. The relationships change. People break up. And it's very sad. It can be quite devastating. But I don't think it's as devastating as staying out of fear of loneliness or what others will think or what you've been taught to believe about yourself that you don't deserve better. You really do. I know I keep saying it. I must sound like a broken record, but it's not your fault that your relationship didn't work out. And I don't think that the only indicator of our self-worth is whether we were able to make a relationship work. There is so much more to you as an individual than this person you're currently with. So I really hope that this episode has helped you if you are thinking about making a certain life decision.
这段关系没有成功。这是人类经历的一部分。人们会改变。你也会改变。关系也会改变。人们会分手。这非常令人难过。甚至可能会带来毁灭性的打击。但我不认为这比出于对孤独的恐惧、对他人看法的在意、或者出于那些被灌输的认为自己不配拥有更好的信念而继续留在错误关系中的打击更大。你真的值得拥有更好的。我知道我一直在重复。我听起来一定像个复读机，但这并不是你的错，你的感情没有修成正果并不是你的错。我不认为我们自我价值的唯一指标，就是我们是否能够维持一段关系的存续。作为一个独立的个体，你的价值远比你目前身边的这个人要丰富得多。所以我真的希望这期节目能对你有所帮助，如果你正在考虑做出某个人生决定，
or you're thinking about perhaps walking away from someone in your life. I just hope that it's given you some more information as to why you're thinking this way, what your brain is kind of battling with, why you are feeling a little bit scared. So I'm really sending you so much love. I'm sending you so much strength. I think that you are doing all the right things. You are thinking critically about your decision.
或者你正在考虑离开你生活中的某个人。我只希望它能为你提供更多信息，让你明白为什么自己会有这种想法、你的大脑在纠结什么、为什么你会感到有点害怕。所以我真的向你发送满满的爱。向你发送满满的力量。我认为你正在做所有正确的事情。你正在对自己的决定进行批判性思考。
You are showing yourself self-love and compassion by listening to podcasts, this, I think you are brilliant. So best of luck with what you're going through. As always, if there is someone out there in your life who needs to hear this episode, please feel free to share it with them. And follow us over at that psychology podcast if you had thoughts, feelings, questions about this episode. If you need advice, anything like that, or if you have an episode suggestion, I'm always on board to hear your ideas. Also, check out my Patreon, like I mentioned at the beginning of this episode. It will be in the episode description, along with some additional resources, information, and where to find me elsewhere. Thank you so much for joining us for this episode.
通过收听像这样的播客，你正在向自己展现自爱与同理心，我认为你太棒了。祝你经历这一切时一切顺利。一如既往，如果你们生活中有人需要听到这期节目，请随时分享给他们。如果你对本期节目有任何想法、感受或疑问，欢迎在那个心理学播客关注我们。如果你需要建议或者类似的事情，或者你有节目建议，我随时都很高兴倾听你的想法。另外，欢迎查看我的 Patreon，就像我在节目开头提到的一样。它将与一些额外的资源、信息以及其他找到我的方式一起放在节目简介中。非常感谢大家收听本期节目。
I really hope you enjoyed it. I hope you got something out of it. And as always, we will be back next week. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
我真心希望你喜欢它。希望你从中有所收获。一如既往，我们下周再见。《2%》。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。经历一些苦难，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。节目英文名为 TWO%，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。在《回顾过去》播客中。从 1979 年开始，这对我是个重大时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·杰伊，我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那些时光的，与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代那样。那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。收听《回顾过去》，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯带来的《艰难中学习》。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都实在不安全的坦诚对话，但你们是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of first. fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once.
有多少男人披着一身铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它。收听《艰难中学习》，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控首次。生下了双胞胎。但这起怀孕事件似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这需要一大批网络侦探出动，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河之网》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
收听《深陷爱河之网》播客，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。这是一档 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。